there's a mega meeting happening today
on the geopolitical landscape we have el
salvador's president president buchelli
going to turkey to meet with president
erdogan now of course everyone knows
turkey is in an economic crisis
president erdogan has been advocating
for low interest rates in an attempt to
spur economic growth anyone who has
stepped in his way who has opposed his
view on low interest rates he's
basically fired he's gotten rid of them
but today ultimately in light of the
turkish lira having lost 40 percent of
its purchasing power over the last 12
months
this meeting is going to be an important
one why el salvador has taken a very
different approach than turkey el
salvador which is a dollarized country
meaning that they have no native
currency they simply use u.s dollars
they've made bitcoin legal tender
they've essentially taken the country of
el salvador and they've tried to plug
their entire country into the bitcoin
network they've gone ahead they've
purchased bitcoin they've given bitcoin
straight to their citizens they've built
a mobile app to actually help more than
four million salvadoreans go ahead and
get on board with lightning network they
also have a network of 200 plus atms
around the country they've announced the
bitcoin city at the foot of one of their
volcanoes they're mining bitcoin using
some of that volcano energy and they
also are issuing a bitcoin-backed bond
over a billion dollars there el salvador
is the bitcoin country but everyone is
expecting president buchelli of el
salvador to talk to president erdogan of
turkey today about becoming the second
bitcoin country what would it look like
if turkey was actually to plug their
country into the bitcoin network could
they solve some of the devaluation of
their currency by simply allowing legal
tender in bitcoin for their citizens
saying to people listen go ahead and
store some of your economic value in
bitcoin why don't we actually go ahead
and plug our country plug our balance
sheet purchase some bitcoin put it on
the turkish balance sheet on top of that
maybe we should use some of our state
resources to mine bitcoin as well no one
knows exactly what's going to happen in
this meeting but all eyes both in the
technology sector and in the bitcoin
world are on this meeting president
buchelli is already orange built he gets
exactly what the value proposition of
bitcoin is and he wants to use this
decentralized digital asset as a way to
leapfrog to the front of the global
stage but can he orange pill president
erdogan from turkey can one president go
ahead and convince the other to plug
their entire country into the bitcoin
network it might not happen overnight
but my guess is don't bet against
president buchelli he's already been
able to rally an entire industry around
his country and if he's able to orange
bill president erdogan today president
erdogan may just take his country plug
it into the bitcoin network and we may
have the second bitcoin country on the
map